how's your brother doing he's doing good
in good spirits in great spirits yeah
he's still locked up right he's still
locked up we hoping he come home 2023.
okay and I say we hoping because he got
a sentence in January and it's gonna be
in the judge hand so he gets out you got
to put him on the twitch [ __ ] man and of
course he got to be the guy who's
holding down the gang while you're
[ __ ] on vacation I'm gonna have him
on that for sure you can't hold down the
grizzly gang online all the time by
yourself yeah yeah you have like I got
guys on there like you got guys yeah my
game be on it down for sure do you have
like guys that like you like are these
guys you've met in person or are they
like people here just know digitally no
some of them I just know digits at least
some of them I met in person though have
you met any of these like when you meet
a guy who you've known through the video
games in person is it kind of crazy to
see what they look like or who they are
or I ain't gonna lie it's been a couple
people it's been a couple people like
damn this [ __ ]
crazy yeah like yeah
I ain't gonna say it any children yeah
yeah I got I got a son yeah you haven't
waited yeah
so you have a son in the game oh no not
in the game other people got kids in the
game I got a son in real life though is
he on the game no no I mean I mean any
children like
a part of your gang that's what I'm
saying like I didn't admit some people
and they've been like 12 but yeah he's
like gang banging this [ __ ] hard enough
yeah like that should be crazy wow
they're like you're on Grizzly game
whatever they really ain't supposed to
be playing it oh I have been eight Euros
on that one [ __ ] before then I met
him they were like yeah I'm searching so
I'm like that's you what the [ __ ] it's
crazy that [ __ ] is wild yeah you ever
have them like try to DM you and then
you're like you see their profile like
oh this is what this [ __ ] look
like oh we gotta kick him out the gang
man no no it ain't never been a
situation like that no the only thing
that surprised me like when I finally
see him is to be real life like kids
sometimes yeah but yeah that's why I I
feel like like all these games online
are just so far past
my learning capabilities to be good at
them and I feel like GTA because I
played I beat GTA obviously but I've
never played online yeah so it's
different I definitely feel like it it
ain't a learning curve though I feel
like with GTA be easy because you're
just running around kind of the only
thing you got to do is just don't break
character that's the only thing that's
the Only Rule Don't Break characters
what if someone does then you get mad
they get exiled you get bent because you
you [ __ ] up the experience for
everybody else what the [ __ ] can I just
I could just go and watch you play right
on Twitch obviously yeah that's [ __ ]
amazing yeah yeah definitely Jesus I
love it man yeah actually the movie for
sure yeah I can't play like uh fortnite
or no no I can't I can't because it's
these little these little kids is too
good I'm starting too late yeah I don't
even play Call of Duty unless it's story
mode so listen you could play Call of
Duty you can actually get good at it you
gotta run with the right team bro
yeah I sucked until I started running
over the right thing most deals suck
yeah
damn that's fire
I got a screenshot it says I get not one
kill whole game
so that would be me because me when I
play fortnite I kind of run around and
hide yeah and wait for the circle to get
smaller and then I'll just go find a new
place and then I'll be like top 10
though yeah and I'd be like [ __ ] I made
it yeah you know what I'm saying but I
can't kill nobody I don't know how to
build nothing new yeah see that's why I
can't focus for tonight because you got
to build and all that I like Call of
Duty if I shoot at you ain't no getting
away from this [ __ ] but there's hackers
on there now it's a bad hackers on there
for the longest yeah they said that
they're like the new uh policy is uh you
have to have a phone number for your
account so they can make sure I don't
know what what that's going to do to cut
it down yeah they selling that [ __ ] I
think
um that yeah the hackers you can't
really be a hacker yeah man they're
selling the hex how much money you got
on GTA in the world like I got about 16
000 but I'm I'm coming up though
in uh in your world yeah you're the
leader of the game you only got 16 bands
in GTA what's going on [ __ ] it's hard
it's [ __ ] up out there damn right now
do you just Rob people
yeah but see I ain't trying to rob
everybody because I got to create
relationships because people starting
this people starting to [ __ ] with me on
the street [ __ ] you know I got like a
half a brick I need to sell that I can't
be robbing people just so we know we're
very clear this is in the video game
yeah this is a video game yeah yeah